each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
I'll go with it wonderful developers
conference every year if you call both
equally people to technology and I can
see the very old map so we named it bar
so i'm probably and slower if you feel
like being a proposal performance
deadline is definitely very much the
developable very interactive work Bobby
there are multiple signal missing for
over I've gone before I really bad day
and which is obviously be repaired on I
think my talked about a year ago and
when i'm working in being and five
remotely cool tube i'm not going over
forward on a virtual we're really
working for flacco from two people that
the music and i came i still working for
something weird Rivera missing problem
and i equals 0 the planet methods come
over and get that negative in working
with a long until nine o'clock try to
attract when some problems and those of
you will be doing ml and dawn and get to
the point where they were using found
new ways of doing things I pickle to the
middle part of again I mean sort of
they're all funky not going to the Bible
that big metal or on board in the bunker
and I would finger off medical director
forget then Roma shouting and barking
never see England and our ultra we are
you know why not set up moving around
and so they knew what I won't be doing
it just is very much and I want to be
here is my people of where I want to
live nope then Wednesday the mountains
in the background like them against
people notable bank nifty and then we
doing bringing getting double size are
going to what kinds of the mountain dog
form deep work in your own bread run I
think we've got some valve is working
but per year and myself and a couple
other people who were goodness to
pumping us constantly get together and
we certainly got the company to score
fasteners but we don't be about
programming from bottle while we ended
you know what a lot of people on the
road yet they blow the money is to be
programming we get local deals with not
be living in some of the big smoking
random or something like that we wanted
finish pinning the right so therefore
ending nice to be by the mountain from
the library
but this before but I painted with the
newer guys do in fifth round back in we
were going to work with the team but
each of it the thing to work in our own
power and for Europe or weho this work
as well as well good wines and
dependability and we go it up in the
next but rather in the first world and I
think I can hope this deep between two
under distress working the 13 build
anticipation whether it is the stupidest
person where you have several departing
after he works in an open in the same
way and using different parts of the
world and they communicate and then I my
mother parole Iraq uniting and
between your simple work like that it's
a comment is broken people talking
packager are going to respond
significantly different column ever
finding the treasure when you collapse
of a single rocket and you have done
most of the work remotely maybe there's
a great first in something on the brink
of people personal concerns
the stick way to refer to the focus on
really dirty in Hong Kong chilli whiskey
it is not really been too hard within
they're not part of their
independence they're not possibly begin
of the back even in that basic with that
be more difficult than finally meeting
the floor name of events are Cockburn
when fasting you negate it should not be
a game in bot mines went to get it in
very difference between to think of us
work in our fight I you taking over the
web you gain well but more things
obviously but also importantly things
and all the technology that we solve for
industry natives and collaborating over
the net detective is one in order to
make it work in order to do we have
found a little fling basic principles
about how we were working together in my
office we have been dying to do the
consultant let me go but only rain
people don't get assume you said no
available that he couldn't work now in
building will be all over you and the
policeman would be familiar anything
so these are for each other if we're
lucky we knew that they did first yakety
yak to communicate them we have with
each other during the bed but there are
people that are about the software we're
developing a normal eating before
present a glass metal but we have got to
be do make very pretty but we
have empowered it perfectly how're we
ever going to work together example well
the things that people do quite a lot
since that was going to run it with care
programs and its people spitting up some
proven then you can do it and over the
web both of the game for you but you
have to think about exactly how you're
going to do that because don't get over
little things about nurse people by
glass dildo and the other people have no
please Oh nonverbal single thing that
you normally get there you have to work
out so it is a big burger it is in what
we were hoping it listening the neck be
don't it the in reacting work you know
one person to another person there
another ball and it hasn't been yeah
from and it's tripping what I've working
like a mental thing and the things that
we just um we all proof I needed up
working more during a lot over to the
new role in the scheme of it's okay
Rohit think more about
24 I'm just with you para la salida y
google buddhist i'm wondering we must
focus so we can go w tree I working for
the man of sin gamma function I've never
realized anything of them but not work
like one waiting and being on personal
commitments don't move around your neck
but is comfy pillow really complete boil
off his you might run getting all
that you can devolve expense and I've
learned quite well fun and with all
cement of our company possible between
ebook going to be a tremendous obstacles
when we approach them both on track your
game is about pop record then your
schedule over the place them and write
our program getting eaten by your
building something like that but back in
with the people were not in awful isn't
thousands body good idea or not and
never be involved the main thing it will
worry about a little bit you're able to
play the movies included a bit we picked
up a while DPM to negate them and that
will affect their problem
with big names of the three basic
equipment we build up from a little
anemic with it would be nice to do this
think i'll give you stay where you want
in not only you don't want to be that
lipid you want to be here speak up and
down the good I boxes show you the
nation to the images taking your life in
conference calling you do a lot of
example the daily meeting of your
software thing you want to open for the
burger at a three-way calling off or or
from Sony's do good point and we can't
afford not to burn music down to 45
million don't you don't know you're
pouring quite well and make an awful lot
if you can steam them we find when you
can hear in the term avoid the value
there looking if you know them you know
what that's about you each week there's
a webcam button or perhaps good very
much extra you like the verify the
network packet with this and got leaked
when you're my all into one more
analytical person of the internet the
public internet the rocks were
definitely think you can get a car
aggressive you can get the built-in to
Reuters
on Lap so those are capable to be
adopted so that we don't always work in
our and whisper fine with each other
compounds visit tiles as well and if you
do that then you want to take your
development and feel it they need a
powerful laptop that you can do all your
development on the run go the dude
database for whatever bit our little
sister you're working on trouble letting
the communication and having a fleet
much in but nothing was the thing that
popped up and then going online but can
we were walking in rural very remote at
the picnic area of making the idea of
care for them then your your please
don't go useful and I've been all other
program literally much just doing what
doing in piping on the screen at the
other end very useful and run a good
couple of this builder which include
from the Greek bore was operated on
then people use that we need I think
about as they would with the process by
which we work river and ordinarily and a
novel of it vocals both combat between
our people and is working in and see if
we are the person who has been to way
they're doing we've all functions we
acting work in the same place together
it would work with the clients so we
would develop this personal contact we
would get dimensional and get to the
point where here the paper better in the
voice yeah and we've got a real that any
person came onto the field then they
definitive sail away one of the few
numbers gimme the keys house work for
being with us and maybe bail on and work
with another question do the tour all
the people they were going to be
workable that you work with importantly
the dispersing Amanda's work you have
the wrong
a week Yeah Yeah right depends I think
she was in the world Wow something I'd
rather than a google i bleep am I want
until the other thing is that a lot of
the people working we work with in your
fitness which will be through them
funding in a
right and in order to complete both are
knocking a cocktail of coming together
we will give an awful of its slipping on
the corn dog at the attitude a daily
pumper stone depicting the next one
another's we're rolling back on the top
of it I'm very regular time component of
our object from eating bad food we buy
that so we're all looking at the same
document or what means we did completely
not inventing Allah we freaking we have
got in with one I believe granted by the
score perform little girl picture time
where everybody is on a formal
conference call remaining other people
that need particular work because people
hold on i'm ready to get people
generally not enough to even if we all
know not to tonight people came to go
climb up on it skype i really just one
thing minister Moshe some more from you
and I believe that work by Road I are
not need to go aided by pointing and
looking to be between we give us to do
make the face of the project very
visible each other become the project
night we go
find out about the techniques they are
open to anything the bug extreme program
great-west and on the project part and
noticed haha yes don't think they
expected from the point of view of our
customers with the baking exactly google
leading to where we were acting a lot
more comfortable without from a get rid
of some of the other people a compact
adaptive who would just go open to an
office and never come and tell them I we
often don't forget to do the end without
our customers to be exactly the same yes
cool Christy very roughly as we were
building our own so we will be very open
visible example and I would neither
tools at our harem of that you have a
web interface a programmable and a
project as a wedding next in Spain our
power functions of which are to be done
with happy people and things like the
name is Coco happy holidays
we've ever welcomed at forgot when
people don't care okay its value you'll
see we've decided i am working on the
road could you bump up the road we're
going to work in paris in programming
the idea is the term you are finally
working the best bit like those of you
in line or open your progress and is
definitely some it open thank the plant
or ego whatever dominates everything
that's undefined very well there is the
object recovering requires that we
understand there are living entity on
people reading documents people of a
very much better idea to do it and a lot
of time did not deliver on things which
happily for those without marriage that
people found whether they work they knew
the whole said the last part was
not only were most often abducted
Oh
including lemon the air example Laurie
Anderson
you
calling them by this madam across
various are tiny crustacean but I
absolutely agree with the other one I'm
not getting people to like it when some
people there I know companies rather
hear it a lot where else can i believe
is drinkability comfortable with I got
herring because being able to compromise
if not yet it will take a backup around
but some of them is going to quickly and
we have to avoid them a program when you
not working to sign of the Allspark
start generating like me to track
to be available they're not change
in fulfilling it we are we did look at
with a number of again of a lamentable
swing by giving this a number printable
and a which server both the box I like
that are equally impact is filed by
doing in there was black the example the
idol have known by shuttle on which
caring advocates having double their
over the concert with me what your up
stuff wasn't doing it right up obviously
needed to do so I was very acting world
with the main kya focused in our program
more transparent than the many comment
will still be productive and pastor of
junior year and then well only have been
crying because very much beyond your own
germs we're doing enduring by the
lunatic I put my laptop yeah but there
were some of the portal connecting for
my lab what like my girlfriend out doing
up hit
it is certainly includes our noses of
with the software oldest and I work I
know is the principle that is crazy
about programmable having the day in the
sun damage and workable back still
focused in proper development name
between crime and those are on improving
with the role where it was work from it
we do that no matter what spot where we
can be anywhere and it just makes me
feel better and family it's both living
is the typical thing people and go
together opinion but for didn't read i
really want to line up your mind so my
colleague blog they do come out there
anything but they're certainly something
i do again being by myself doing AI
think even my only added being expensive
compared with law can prevent it
you
for the day we can really found the
audio being there is no reliable up
well actually I mean remember it the
army where you work with incremental to
an
three
that does it everybody but I find it by
talking about I am engaging with other
my friend but otherwise keep on
forgetting ordinarily I offer
programming for my folk Bertha mouth
like yeah let me come to 4.8 the book
but what that means your customer belong
he contracted in one of a kind of
terrifying and the rig doesn't let's
talk about the big look a bit of
background about I are believing it's
about move by the back way you're
infected with the Google at all around
but so we can factor of people
throughout the number of Fashion Week
will come from the company workforce to
do atoms of topics every last year
Oh